this video is brought to you by better
help as two people proud to be in
therapy we are excited to be sponsored
by them for the month of November more
on them after the reaction I ain't
afraid to know ghosts at 8 in the
morning after working on a Marvel's edit
late at night guys how are you John how
are you I'm ready to ascend to the
afterlife after the religious experience
of a new Ghostbusters tra I know we're
finally getting a sequel to the Melissa
McCarthy one that we've all been waiting
for my God Kristen wig is back
leave a
like let's do it
guys yeah okay here we go back in NY SE
it's going to be another hot one out
there for there are heat alerts in
effect for New Jersey feeling like
that's
cool that's right we were a small town
last time
man Cruel
Summer on my
own
something spooky is happening theme park
ghosts what is
that oh something malevolent is coming
our way to attack the Ivo shandor
Beachside
Carnival oh damn whoa destruction is
huge on this
one this looks like a Rolland Emer movie
now
yeah that's what we need $200 million
Ghostbusters huh
neat full on action movie first time in
New York history
people in the middle of July wolf
character what is
it the power to kill oh they're
just showing them in the trailer they're
all back turn the rivers of ice was he
the Ghostbusters outfit Paul R and the
last thing you see oh even te guts
freezing
up wa literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool wow the Ghostbusters team is really
expanded this time it's all about
[Music]
family
wa keeping that scientific enthusiasm
alive that nerdiness oh man oh man hey
you know that that wasn't a bad look not
at all not at all and it's a very
distinct look going with this whole ice
thing oh yeah of course you know I think
though too when you are like a family
and you are also working together a lot
of times communication is very very
important where you have to learn to be
honest with everyone around you hey John
you know what can you st out the video
for just one it's a little wiping thank
you to better help for sponsoring this
video I've literally just finished a
therapy session and I wanted to shoot
this cuz I'm in this state of knowing
why I Champion mental health support so
much in the past few weeks work's been a
little bit hectic it's led me to miss
some sessions and I really don't like
doing that and sometimes that's when the
weight really starts to pile on a lot of
restless nights a lot of fatigue a lot
of I can't sleep even though I'm so
tired sometimes just a very deep-seated
sense of gloom and yeah every time this
time of year I get the seasonal Blues
like many of you meditating and
sometimes journaling are my daily go-tos
but sometimes they just don't cut it
when I'm trying to pinpoint why I'm down
and really especially after a session
like today therapy just really helps
clear the fog discussing the feelings is
a critical step for me especially as
someone who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2
bipolar and PTSD it's truly a
Cornerstone of my well-being and I'm not
alone in this many of us here at real
rejects are in therapy facing our own
challenges from depression to anxiety or
just needing to nonjudgmental space to
voice our thoughts this year I've been
working on most days of the week to keep
my physical health strong and I really
do Champion therapy as a way to
strengthen my mental resilience and for
many betterhelp is integral to that
process There's real value in better
help's accessible and adaptable service
they match you with a licensed therapist
and provide the option to switch if
necessary ensuring the right fit for
your mental health Journey as this year
winds down and we confront life's
complexities do consider better help as
a resource really happy to be partner
with them this month so you can go to
betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off your
first month again that's BT R
hp.com slre rejects so join us in moving
forward stronger together thank you
again a but seriously thank you better
help for uh sponsoring this video Yeah
know that was a delightful looking
trailer I mean the first one or not the
first one but the last one which I guess
is technically the real part three had
more of that small town flare where
you're introducing the new characters
and then the old characters coming for a
very special Cameo at the end and then
the fact that they're showing them in
the trailer here I don't imagine they're
going to be super prevailing from
beginning to end or anything of that
sort I imagine there'll still be an
extended Cameo but maybe borderline
extended Cameo meets supporting role
somewhere there they'll have a few
different opportunities to check in with
them and get Sage advice as to how to
handle this unprecedented ghost
situation well you know what I I really
liked the small town focus of the last
one and what I think is really cool
about here is like yes we're are going
back to the Big Apple um but we got a
brand new villain in the form of Elsa
from Frozen but the malevolent version
right yeah man if Elsa was also
Maleficent what we need yeah I know I
mean there is something cool about
actually getting in a like it's been a
while since we've gotten like just a
fullon new villain right because even
like the Remake one which was loved by
all audiences uh teror doogs and Evo
shandor and it was riffing on the
original Slimer but basically yeah yeah
and then the one last time was just
resurrecting old villains for the most
part and then here we got a brand new
look with a brand new aesthetic and uh I
I like I like the cast from the prior
one I thought film wolfart was okay in
this one so I'm hoping that they really
uh utilize him a little more my remember
mechanic Grace was a real highlight here
but I'm excited for the entire big cast
and for Paul rud's scientific scientist
character to be such a Ghostbusters
Enthusiast to now be a Ghostbuster this
time around yeah yeah I mean it takes
that that I don't know there's something
about again like the tone of these and
and like the original ghost boers I
think as as is now well Trot in
territory is like an irreverent comedy
that isn't exactly in line with like the
reverence people have for it now and so
I feel like looking at a trailer like
this is kind of fun and interesting
because I'm getting a better sense of
what Ghostbusters fans may want if they
like this because this has more of that
sort of like yeah Goonies esque thing I
assume uh where it's like
you I don't know it's it's like more of
a rag tag band with a sort of sense of
heart that's a little different than
what I associate with like the actual
Ghostbusters but that I think works well
for what this new generation wants to be
you've got the Spangler family now kind
of all just living this Ghostbusters
life and Paul Rudd's you know continuing
to just you know he's part of that now
um and so you know it makes sense to me
and then coming back to the familiar
setting but with what appears to be a
new and actually just sort of original
hook villain character true it's kind of
kind don't know it's got me cautiously
optimistic again well yeah I mean I they
got a different director this time
around uh Gil Keenan from monsterous
yeah and I just saw monster house for
the first time and I thought that was a
really good family accessible horror
film that had a great bit of Whimsy
Wonder but did maintain horror and the
last movie um while you know fans really
like that one a lot that was a little
bit more zeroed in on Nostalgia and but
also the uh you know a little bit more
of just the heart of it of the
character- driven heart which was
probably the right step to bringing back
the franchise and then here this is
really bringing back the horror because
I haven't forgotten the like
Ghostbusters is a horror comedy you know
and then right from the get-go like you
can see that with the way this movie is
being framed as the cinematography
everything about it looks very much
composed and I'm excited for the blue
aesthetic that is going to linger
throughout like you can feel an animated
director's presence sort of all over
this trailer and I'm excited to see
whatever uh new look they bring to it
but yeah you know um Ghostbusters is is
a is an easy franchise for me to
immediately go watch I I I just love the
idea of them uh the original is one of
my all-time favorite movies I think it's
a near Perfect film other than the fact
that Bill Murray's character may have
aged into more of a creep over time you
know is a creep yeah well I mean I don't
know that's always the funny thing is
like if you look at the original
Ghostbusters like these guys are are
like not exactly the warmest cuddliest
you know most access old movie Let It Go
well let it go let it go I find it funny
that yeah people people basically want
an amlin movie out of something that
originally wasn't that but that's fine
and I also like the Amin movie yeah and
now it's it's got that sort of wonder
that reverence that nostalgic quality
but you know it's it's reaching a fuller
final form it seems like I do like the
idea of them doing like a summertime
thing here too parts that were reminding
me of something like I don't know any
any number of beach related horror
movies
the yeah exactly so you know that's kind
of a fun aesthetic to go with yeah man I
mean it's coming on IMAX and looks like
this looks like a cool IMAX experience
if fact that we got this director
especially it's like the last movie I
wouldn't associate as like something
that was like it looked good but I
wouldn't say it was like visually
appealing and this feels like there's
going to be a visual Feast behind it
while still having um a fun Ensemble to
behold but guys what did you think about
this Ghostbusters Frozen empire trailer
the trailer didn't do anything here to
Warrant any concern necessarily other
than like yeah the plot doesn't it
didn't clue us into too much anything on
the plot I'm excited for it man I I
don't want I have nothing to hate on
this one about I'm trying to find
something where I don't look like a kiss
ass but I liked it I liked it John I
liked it a lot yeah I'm happy I'm happy
we're cautiously optimistic yeah
cautiously I'm very optimistic yeah
ready for to the chil as long as the
third act doesn't just become like hey
let's just transplant the third act to
Ghostbusters and did this again it
worked for a lot of people maybe not for
us but it work for everyone you know
what they should do is just bait and
switch everybody pretend this movie is
real to show the original Ghostbusters
when you get there I'm I'm totally cool
with that Humphrey all righty gang well
thank you so much for being here what
did you think about the Ghostbusters
Frozen Empire trailer are you excited
for it leave your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe leave a like thank you
to Better h help once again we will
catch you all
[Music]
soon